dude you promise not to get mad at me no
I won't ever get mad at you ever what
you got okay so I guess that counts
Sanchez we ready okay I'm talking like
this yet
are we ready no it's so
I hear the crowd splendid I guess not
honestly we have all been on stage when
something's happened in the back and
you're trying to fill but that know what
would that feel like because I didn't I
was I was standing off the side and I
didn't have to come out for incident at
that moment I usually wait to the music
starts come on you don't say yeah it's
time I I got the cue musics ready
he's cued up I can go out there no cube
nothing hits it's nothing starts so now
I'm like holy [ __ ] I'm out here no music
get him talk to the crowd a little bit
which is no big deal and for me it was
fine you know I it was a little big deal
like as soon as I'd you know are you
ready
you know I guess not no you held out no
I so long like I know that you were five
seconds into ready and you're like drop
the [ __ ] beat bro so holla when that
happens you get done and you walk off
and you're like man that [ __ ] sucked
but like whatever I'm in Milwaukee like
not a big deal how soon did it go from
that to like oh no no actually see the
whole situation is craziest because
after that I said are you ready whatever
we did drop the beat and I'm rock no
issues no anything after that somebody
takes that clip and doctors it and makes
the crowd mute when I'm saying are you
ready
so you hear it nothing and not it and
that's everybody
it was crickets nobody was cheering or
anything for job world and it's just
this complete [ __ ]
just listen in the crowds chair anyway
you know they they trying to figure out
what's going on and then Yanis even they
tried to get Yanis to just to say
something bad about me now yeah what
happens when and ja Rule and Yanis was
like what do you mean that's an Apple
job where's my keys messed up and so I
this is so crazy
now if you find anything the Polka got
you on the internet but this one is so
you can't expect anything different